disgraced celebrity lawyer michael
avenatti sentenced to two and a half
years in jail
for scheme related to suing nike if you
don't recall michael avenatti
represented a putative whistleblower who
said that nike was paying high school
and college students
to sign nike endorsement deals which was
of course illegal but the problem for
avenatti is that not only was he trying
to get money for his client he was also
trying to get money for himself he tried
to extort nike for
millions of dollars so that he could run
an internal investigation
of nike's practices and he'd get paid as
a consultant pro tip as a lawyer you are
not allowed to do that
so a jury convicted avenatti on three
counts related to extortion
interstate communications related to
extortion and wire fraud and he now has
been sentenced to two and a half years
in jail
and on top of that he faces other
charges in california where he could
face even more time in jail so
we're definitely going to see michael
avenatti in court